i want to call this a must
win for mania because it's not but it is
very important that the astros don't get
the two-nothing advantage in this
five-game series
that is strike three and springer knew
it takes with him the first k of the day
for mania lots more chances yesterday to
do more damage than they already did and
they take game one
here's a grounder to third base pender
who flips the second underhanded long
way and falling at the plate was bradley
he didn't even get out of the box
where the athletics got to get to him
early and they're trying to do that here
one out in the second inning and chris
davis
there's a fly ball set to center field
springer going back battling the sun
that'll take him at the wall take it out
of the yard it's a home run chris davis
hovered yesterday homers again today and
puts the athletics on top one to nothing
springer had a beat on it until he
didn't it's out of the yard
just two home runs during the regular
season for davis he's got two in this
series
two down reddick still at first top of
the order george springer
springer will lift this in the air to
left center field and deep back goes to
center philadel at the wall it's gone
george springer hits a two run home run
and puts the astros on top two to one
with one swing of the bat
14 home runs during the regular season
and he homers here a two-run shot the
astros have the lead
never had a home run against mania in
the past he does now
first in third now with one out and it
brings up carlos correa batting out of
the
sixth spot in the order for the astros
runner goes in first and correa
groundswell is short
he'll go to first for the outer runnel
score in the back door from third comes
brantley and it's three to one astros on
top
so two down tucker in scoring position
now at second base and here's guriel
who grounded out to shortstop in the
third he's over one
and a grounder right side this time
stella in the outfield grass throws him
out and ends the inning but the astros
had a run to their total but a good
opportunity here for the a's to get back
in this ball game with their three big
righties here three four five
this is in the year to right center
field that struck well back towards the
pavilion and gone
officer field home run for chad pender
had two during the regular season
it's in the three spot today for bob
melvin and hits one out of the yard that
makes it a one-run contest
matt olsen tells me this guy's got as
much opposite field pop as anybody on
the team
there's a one out here in the fifth and
otto will drive this to deep left center
field back goes kenny turns around and
it'll go
home run maldonado
and the astros have their two-run lead
back again
it's now 4-2
home run number two of the day for the
astros
into this game is yasmiro petite
and here's a drive to deep left field
off the bat at george springer and he's
left the yard again
into the pavilion in left field for
springer he homered in the third first
pitch thrown by petite here in the fifth
he takes out of the yard and the astros
are on top now five to two back to back
they go against two oakland relievers in
the fifth
and valdez pitching here into the fifth
and just a couple of mistakes really i
guess prestigious the home run try to
pinder the home run but that's been it
really for him today
moriano will take strike three and
strikeout number four for valdez out
number two of the fifth inning
brought it back up the middle but to the
backhand goes altuve up into the air
with the throw and he gets it there in
time nice stretch by goriel also at
first base good play at both ends more
ground ball out seduced by valdez and
that's down four ground ball outs in a
row here's the 3-2 pitch curve ball and
it's hitting the center field and
springer is going to have room about
three steps shy of the warning track and
valdez through seven innings has a 5-2
lead
the astros trying to make it 2-0 in the
american league division series so it's
now 11 in a row retired by astros
pitching
swing and a miss and laureato strikes
out
that's pretty nasty pitch goes to the
slider there for out number two of the
eight they got brady's out there now and
with two down grossman trying to get a
two out rally started
and he'll send it to center springer
coming in a step for two has out number
three as we head to the bottom of the
ninth inning as ryan presley the closer
into this game for the astros in a save
situation
the 2-2 pitch
and ground ball headed to shortstop
correa the second for one on to first
that's two and that's the ball game is
the astros on the double play
in this one and take it five to two
and it is the astros who have won the
first two games of this best of five
in this american league division series